[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin ein hoffnungsloser
optimist
[Musik]
sie hatten
ich bin emotional wunder hat die person
in der rolle der ehefrau und ein ist
schlecht hatte ich besonders
die geschichte beginnt 2013
dennis und agiler werden ein liebespaar
sechs monate später diagnostiziert man
bei dem es die unheilbare
nervenkrankheit l&s mit einer
lebenserwartung von drei bis fünf jahren
daniela entscheidet sich an seiner seite
zu bleiben
ein jahr später 2015 kommt minister zur
welt
während die tochter an lebenskraft
gewinnt baut der vater ab
doch die familie kämpft für ein
selbstbestimmtes leben
[Musik]
es ist die geschichte von daniela und
dennis die sich trotz diagnose für eine
familie entschieden haben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ein volksschüler sagt
amyotrophe lateralsklerose
kurz als
die nervenkrankheit lähmt schrittweise
die muskulatur bei dennis zuerst hände
dann arme und beine
über die lähmung der atemmuskulatur
führt die krankheit binnen weniger jahre
zum tod
neun von zehn betroffenen sterben in der
drei bis fünf jahren nach der diagnose
denn es hat glück im unglück
der 50 jährige hat einen langsamen
verlauf er erhielt die ls diagnose vor
acht jahren
seit einem jahr baut dennis kiefer und
zungenmuskulatur habe essen und sprechen
werden immer schwieriger bis es gar
nicht mehr geht
[Applaus]
die so der kriminalist rand er hat das
stück fleisch gestellt und ich habe
recht sagt sie und hat er nicht immer
gestimmt und ich kann es jetzt los ist
ich sonst aber geschluckt und steckte
und das probiert
und dann ist alles so
schlimm artig dann hat er sich einen
ausrutscher mit mehr wie wirken
und ist jetzt so
im rechtsstreit mit
kollegen
und sieht dann schnittig dialog ich
halte sich nicht so große stücke
schneiden von fleisch nicht so gut ich
unterzeichnen aber auch schlicht aber
aus dem markt aber
glücklos
die krankheit hat das leben von daniela
und dennis auf den kopf gestellt
damit gehen sie ganz unterschiedlich um
[Musik]
immer wieder schön sind ich lektüre ist
denn so einfach und abermals gegen die
emotional gestört ist kann man nicht
einfach fokussiert
dann ist das schwierig da sie oftmals
positiver als halterung
[Musik]
das macht
kein schiff mehr lehrer mehr vom spiel
und und also ist
der welt so cool das
gesundheits- und was
nicht und
eltern sind voll drauf
an seiner leidenschaft und dem
volleyball club btv aarau hält er fest
früher als spieler in der ersten
mannschaft heute als coach
in den schlaf vom körper sitzt ein
unverändert wacher geist
[Musik]
einen finger kann er noch bewegen für
den ist der zugang in eine barrierefreie
und unabhängige welt in naher zukunft
wird er diese über eine augensteuerung
betreten
[Musik]
gedacht ist auch an der person hält
deshalb einfach doof und irgendwann ist
aber
ja noch
denn ist der sportler und kämpfer
das credo weiterleben wie vor der
krankheit
[Musik]
sein wichtigstes ziel hat er schon
erreicht
tochter melissa bis ins
kindergartenalter zu begleiten
mittlerweile ist melissa
[Musik]
fünfjährigen griff bewundern
ich möchte mit ihm freuen dass das ich
nur bis haben vor ihm
bis gemeinsam mit besonderen teile
räumen hälfte vor ihm am
ball setzte man sich und eine schmal und
die bewertung woche meine es wird nach
dem mega schwierig für sie und mehr sind
schuld wenn es jetzt bald gesetzt hat im
wissen dass
die elftal vielleicht man in der 14
dennis langsamer krankheitsverlauf sowie
abklärungen zur vererbbarkeit stärken
das paar in seinem kinderwunsch
[Musik]
sei
normal und er wollte vom
also als
gesenkt
dennis möglichkeiten bei haushalt und
erziehung anzupacken wurden immer
kleiner
alles wäre er will aber nicht die
schönste schwierigkeit als kontrast
zwischen lotte und
wichtigste sache sehr präzise und
und da scheint aber so dass grund ein
mann von der
[Musik]
heute unterstützen assistenz personen
und spitex die familie bevor schneiders
externer hilfe holten lastete das meiste
auf der heute 34 jährigen daniela
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja
genau
[Musik]
gemeinsame ausflüge bringen licht den
zunehmend schweren alltag
[Musik]
mir macht es spaß 12
miteinander spielerfahrung es mache den
spaß hand wenn ich es erlebt mit ihm für
uns machen und da schreiber für mich
8.15 und
einfach nur aber so kunz weiter bis
walter barhocker da stehen wo wir nach
diesem spiel
die eltern klären melissa so gut es geht
über die krankheit auf
[Musik]
und vorbereitet die treffen mit wo sie
dann halt dort wo sie dann halt das
macht mich computer kommunizieren und
wenn das system aufgenommen
ja meine damals sie will dass das sei
halt immer ihrem herz wird blieben dem
man da bloß ist
[Musik]
die ursache von l s mit ausnahme der
seltenen erblichen formen ist bisher
unbekannt
pro jahr trifft es ein bis zwei von
100.000 personen in der schweiz leben
rund 600 menschen mit ls
[Musik]
das bier
energie
schweiz heimlich natürlich eine zubewegt
ich weiß das haben die un am ehesten und
es geht schön ist dass wir nach besuch
statt das heißt hartz iv
kinder nachts das hat sich zum
tabu sei
danielas überbelastung und der
unterschiedliche umgang mit dem
schicksal belasten die beziehung
machen
und dann
ist mein
[Musik]
album nicht
ganz einfach also muss sie dann vor
aber schwarz und da könnten sie von den
herrschern und nach hilfe und
sie würden sagen denn
dann auch
erhalten hat und gern unterstützen
behalten mit mir und nach einer nichts
bekommen aufmerksamkeit
heißt stadtbezirk hat mir jeden tag
nicht der viele jobs wie du bist das
etwa vier jahre lang die zweite
stimme meine eigene stimme
ich versteh ich bin nicht so toll wie
früher ich mache immer noch viel habe
ich meine grenzen und
wir
werden halt recht aggressiv impulsiv
das ist verständlich dass er mich nicht
gegeben hat dann in dem moment
kann ich nicht sagen wann ich schlecht
drauf bin zu dick zum freitagmorgen
später kann ich mich wenigstens ein
kuschel und die no name
ja
mutter ehefrau pflegerin und
berufstätige kriminaltechnikerin
daniela wird alles zu viel sie begibt
sich in psychotherapie und mietet eine
einzimmerwohnung
vier wände wo sie momente versichert
[Musik]
billige hollywood-
büro aber ich habe es geschafft
sportlich haben die aufständischen sie
erfordert wünscht kann dann schauen was
der grund war nicht mein tag
ich bin ich
halte es aber nicht
also lieber ihre
bürgschaft brüllt
beschäftigt ich habe immer wieder so
minimiert fauser
wo
ich bin und dann keine single aber
gesehen
und gefühlt werden hier glücklich im
umfeld macht vollumfänglich an der
heimat bin
ich meine normale familie wünsche und
dann denke ich mir
nicht mal als pflegerin
fertig aber
schon etwas was soll ich noch einen
glücklich macht das geht nicht
[Musik]
auf empfehlung der psychotherapeutin
entscheidet sich daniela für einen
klinikaufenthalt
sechs wochen in denen es nur um sie geht
[Musik]
in die gleiche zeit fällt der
vierwöchige reha aufenthalt von dennis
müller ist derweil bei einer
befreundeten familie untergebracht
[Musik]
und dann dreimal hinein husten nicht
pusten husten ja so und gucken aber wie
weit dass sie kommen
und noch mal tief luft holen und kräftig
[Musik]
was er gut 12 ja da war besser
wegkommen
also wir sind bei
ungefähr
320 liter pro minute
und das ist weit im grünen bereich
hls ist nach heutigem stand der
forschung unheilbar mit physiotherapie
und lohmen training kann der verlauf
etwas hinausgezögert und die
befindlichkeit verbessert werden
einmal im jahr wird die cau und schlug
muskulatur getestet
jetzt die frau schüler gibt ihnen ein
löffel muss das ist grün gefärbt mit
lebensmittelfarbe damit wir den kontrast
gut sehen
was ist jetzt nicht so die aller falls
die kraft also es ist ein kleines
bisschen weniger kräftig als sein sollte
das hört sich das komplette ja oder noch
so ein bisschen fester sich schliefen
genommen und das hört man auch schon an
ihrer stimme weil dann ist das ein ganz
klein bisschen nasal sagen wir den genau
eine genaue prognose für dennis weiteren
verlauf gibt es nicht er selber fühlt
sich in der halbzeit seit der diagnose
und rechnet mit weiteren acht
lebensjahren
während vier wochen lebt melisa bei der
nachbarsfamilie mit drei kindern
ich denke sie macht mit bei uns zu
anfang als in minecraft promi familie
einfach arbeit weil
wir
geschichten erzählen und da hab ich dann
mache ich auch dass sie gott mit
munition mit materie kinski und sie wird
wie gut und richtig dass ich ständig
viel einfacher für sie weil sie spielen
was kann schon auch im slowenisch sagt
eva maria pieckert
und was heißt das
am sonntag am wochende gehen wir alle
das ist super dann kommt man
[Musik]
nach vier wochen reha sind dennis und
melissa wieder zu hause
danielas klinikaufenthalt wird indes um
vier wochen verlängert assistenz
personen spitex freunde und dennis
eltern übernehmen haushalt und pflege
ja
so
[Musik]
nein
und noch einmal zwei
handvoll helfer
da
und
[Musik]
wenn ich es falsch ist weil ich dann
nicht überfordert ich
mache einfach und weil es wenn sie das
problem hat
oder man macht
einfach
mannschaft
phase nach dem bösen
olaf sein muss ist fange ich würde mir
das halten von
sophos
wenn sie jetzt das derzeitig horst und
doch machen im laufe
des frühlings
mai ist das körper
ist hier her war
[Musik]
rheinfelden im kanton aargau seit neun
wochen dreht sich hier danielas welt nur
um sie im gespräch schmal und
bewegungstherapien findet sie zurück ins
gleichgewicht
ich habe wieder zu mir gefunden ich kann
viele entspannungstechniken
kennengelernt und um das gefühl ich hat
dann 67 woche braucht wieder gemerkt
haben und erkannten und realisiert haben
dass es da eigentlich geht kann es ganz
einfach geld ab lockt natürlich und mini
bedürfnisse und die grenze und seinem
egoismus zu sein einfach
selbst lebe verschaffte tanz und das
alles stimmt dann kann ja das andere
meister bin ich ja
gewappnet mit
chor wurde da stand als einziger des
zoos und begleiter wird
es schwierig sagen ich bin emotional
bunter hat die person und irgendein ist
schlecht hatte ich das animus lichte
untergang weg zur lage und das mit macht
andererseits auch wie lange mag minister
und das mitmachen egal gesetzt mit ihrem
kühlungs sobald sie nach einem elite als
freund hat beim backen natürlich findet
nur noch bettlägerig und nicht
kommunizieren
verantwortlich
[Musik]
ein halbes jahr liegt hinter danielas
klinikaufenthalt
dank einer strukturierten wochenplanung
und zusätzliche hilfe nimmt sie sich
regelmäßig auszeiten
[Musik]
in welche richtung rennt ihm aus dazu
brauchst du
[Musik]
noch ängstlich aber zuversichtlich es
ist schon lange weg
immer wieder
stolperstein
ja aber sie stickt bahn steckt und
schnell abgestürzt das konstrukt hat
kalte
im neuen jahr will die mutter
schrittweise zur arbeit zurückkehren
dennis will auf einer homepage seine
geschichte erzählen und tipps für ein
selbstbestimmtes leben mit a ls
festhalten